enfin vous êtes pas quand même à
vraiment à la veille de la retraite à
partir de quand une femme est trop
vieille à la télévision maintenant
l'attention en divertissement c'est plus
compliqué je dis pas que c'est
impossible mais c'est plus compliqué
parce que vous avez quand même des
critères physiques et c'est normal enora
tu es d'accord avec moi j'imagine mais
moi ça mais si pire que ça c'est que le
système de la télé est à vous venir en
fait c'est que jason revient ménard d'un
risque à l'antenne je suis évidemment
beaucoup plus grossières que sandrine
m'efface verser une évidence qu'à partir
de 40 ans quel que soit d'ailleurs le
divertissement le journalisme peu
importe vous êtes à bonne à jeter aux
toilettes on fait de la télé ce n'est
pas le cas d'un homme c'est pas vrai
pour toutes les femmes mais quasiment
95% aller arlette chabot et la fer de
lance est parti faire ses bars est
énorme et il faut arrêter src absolument
c'est le mieux le plus sexistes qui soit
fin des milieux les plus sexistes et
qu'on vous fait clairement comprendre
que de toute façon si vous songé à
partir
on va vous dégager de toute façon la
télé c'est une c'est une engeance
c'est comme ça moi j'ai tu te relâches
on fait de la télé vous crachez sur la
télé donc ça c'est un poids ça c'est un
truc qui me mets moi j'ai effectivement
songé à l'argent quoi filmer c'est dans
trois ans et féminin moi je trouve quand
même
or pouvant voyager en regardant les tdr
de l'extérieur je trouve qu'à la télé il
ya quand même des endroits aujourd'hui
chez ruquier ici chez nous l'eau le
plein d'endroits à la télé aujourd'hui
on peut quand même s'amuser à regarder
des choix tu as rim semble quand même
qu'anne sinclair a fait aussi vision je
crois pas que ce soit un homme non plus
je vois je suis tu je suis extrêmement
féministe et je pense que c'est vrai tu
as raison la société très en retard sur
les femmes mois en france que dans
d'autres pays mais encore en france
beaucoup quand même
malgré tout j'aime pas trop moi à
utiliser le système binaire de la
comparaison je tape sur machin pour cgem
barbara mais je tape assure mireille
mathieu pour autant parce que chacune
d'entre elles ont fait leur carrière
elles ont du talent toutes les deux donc
je ne me suis jamais placer là où vous
là c'est vous et moi j'en aime choquer
donc je comprends que j'avais déjà
d'autres personnes je tape sur un
système quel système français qu'est
main plantu dit qu ils ont foutu est là
qu ils nous ont foutu à la porte alors
qu'elle du nom m'a pas foutu à la porte
non j'en avais pensé à la remplacer ceux
dont elle a aussi entendu par l'ex n'a
pas été le cas que je trouve assez
injuste après aussi par exemple la
première chaîne de télévision avoir mis
un homme de couleur au journal de tf1 au
journal c'était fin bon il se trouve que
c'est eux qu'il n'en c'était un petit
vie bien avant
non non je pars en france en france
aussi par exemple en fin d'audience
ça a été quelque chose qui tient qui
était intéressant mais si vous êtes
objectif maintenant vous êtes payés par
tf1 je suis très je suis très ami avec
le chèque j'ai pas de copain je vais pas
l'acheter parce que c'est pas mon métier
parce qu'au final je fais pas l'émission
de vote parce que c'était fin fait
l'émission the voice parce que j'ai
envie de rencontrer des jeunes talents
voilà pourquoi ça se ferait sur canal +
je le ferai sur canal + je n'ai aucun
problème je ne préfère pas tes fans ce
n'est pas la télé chez moi pour vous
dire